all right we'll do a little cartridge I
love every magician has to do a card
trick all right hot dog I know you know
a few card tricks accident we were doing
a couple things actually pretty good out
of understand here love them okay so go
ahead and take a card out be any when
you like take it out look at them and
board it it so you show it to everybody
I will look out alternative monitor
don't look at its right to good
everybody I got hide it for me I'm
Trebek okay now try and remember it it
helped you look like anybody will help
up here get humanik device magicians are
the worst remember in cards we've
remembered so many in our lifetime okay
I can so like I was pretty good he put
exactly 26 cards down you even though
you did that did you well that's that's
pretty impressive I know
stop do you are the best way to mixing
cards beat no I guess we read right
oh I don't hear that's out of here you
go engineer playing okay yes and then we
do barrel rolls okay and you put the
deck on the floor that would probably
the best way yeah I agree but with in
person the best way is with one hand
alright this is impossible to fake with
one hand that's a lot of practice is
like five years five years without a
date never try Oh
not worth it alright when I don't have a
date I do something else with a vacuum
which there's no playing with the dance
so I'm talking but the best way the best
way is to do 53 card pick up every done
that before yeah sure yeah more than
once like a real bully we'll go yeah
he's good right yeah like I'm gonna
simulate excite I want to make a mess
here on the floor so I'm gonna take half
turn and face down the other half face
up and then I'll mix them together like
this so you can see red cards you can
see black cards yeah up spades hearts
clubs diamonds this decks about as mixed
up as I am right beat would you answer
that some are face up somewhere face
down I'm gonna find your card with some
sleight of hand good old-fashioned
inside of hand here we go I don't need
it 5 moves 1 2 3 4 5 is your card the
nine of Hearts yes
hey you need to come here here they come
here to see sleight of hand
is it all about siding we don't see some
magic see controlling one card outside
of Hannah's one team but to do every
card use a little extra power so you
know every car the deck is face down
every single card except for one the
night of hearts but wait wait gonna have
high standards in that okay now if you
gotta mix the cards you should also be
able to uncouple them to see ace through
King of clubs ace through King of Hearts
ace through King of Spades diamonds all
the way through but wait the best part
you put your car back right in the
perfect position right between the 8th
and a let's give it up for Pete home
this guy's amazing tell you what we'll
take it a step farther all right
you had that knock the nine of Hearts
nine of Hearts nine of Hearts is in the
center of the deck alright think of the
nine of Hearts watch I just stopped my
fingers one two three do you see I just
did there you know some that split
second you're a nine of Hearts
disappeared as I go through you'll see
between there's one missing it's not
there all the way through the nine of
Hearts is now gone from the deaf being
Carl I'm right here where did it go
where did it go nothing up my sleeves I
roll them all the way up be so
discipline side my pocket inside the
card box fold in half not once but twice
then rolled like a little tiny golf
pencil is his card the nine of Hearts
yeah what hold your hand out
inside is a knife and a lime
this is the world's most sublime card
trick
check it out look I take it like this
inside of the line I'm not with that
negative attitude is a card I'll pull it
out that's a wet one it is what this is
the monkeys enjoy the whole day and I
can't do it well there we go
I ripped it but there is a nine of
Hearts really incredible
hopper top everybody